germany we've been told it's a beautiful
city
let's explore it together
let's go
what a beautiful building
look at the tower
beautiful
architecture and here's a shop in
colonial style
so many memories
how terrific
there was a tin like this in my
grandmother's house
how pretty
tins for coffee and tea
my grandparents emigrated from germany
to the river vulgar
and they certainly had this kind of tea
tin in one of the few pieces of luggage
they had
if only my grandmother could see this
look at this this is hamburg's old port
you can feel its impressive history
and here's some modern day architecture
it's really overwhelming
this contrast between modern
architecture mixed with old buildings
it's really a good idea to mix the two
architectural styles
to make a new design
here's the immigration museum
we have to visit that
because my great-grandparents and
grandparents left from there
it interests me a lot
we have a suitcase like this at home
it belonged to my grandmother and must
be a hundred years old it's a real relic
south america
my grandparents and parents worked the
land with animals like this
now we keep horses as pets
because technology has changed
everything
today horses are mascots
i have a watch like this from my
grandparents
thanks a lot and goodbye to everyone